hello and welcome to the new world
review where we're going to take three
deep breaths together to just calm down
we're going to come right down and have
the most quiet episode we've ever had
I'm not going to steal your soul or
mangle your manga or abscond with your
anime let's just relax and take a quiet
nap for know what were you thinking it's
landline waifu punching you in the face
with entertainment like a Hisoka to the
jaw I'm here with episode 17 and 18 like
a lean mean anime review and Queen and I
mean business always business if you
like business slam your mouse button
onto that like button too many button if
you really like business say BAM while
you do it because that's always
satisfying to say if you don't like
business say up now
while you sadly click that dislike
button either way we are here for
spoilers spoil is what you will be never
say I don't give you anything let's get
started to put it simply after all my
excitement to start this review episode
17 was boring but that's okay not every
episode can be the most energetic and
nor should every episode be energetic if
every episode or chapter of anything was
highly charged you wouldn't and couldn't
read or watch it there's only so far you
can go up before you crush down with
that in mind this was a nice down point
basically I appreciated it what for what
it was quinoa got to play with people
and I always love to watch killer play
with people because we as an audience
aren't new to cures power it's no longer
a surprise when other characters
underestimate him so while the story has
characters trying to creep up on him and
take him out it's treated as a farce
which we absolutely know it is Kilwa has
these characters outmatched and outpaced
at every turn so watching him
effortlessly find what he's looking for
and get it leaves us with as much
boredom as he has I'm finally feeling
deliberately bored though I think people
forget the boredom is a stepping stone
to creativity or extreme emotion as I
said last episode I get the sense where
galloping toward the end of an arc and
so an episode like this is like the tide
pulling away before throwing us into a
whole lot of strife
despite the boredom I enjoyed Kiawah
playing with our bald-headed pretty boy
left in a spotlight something I'm
noticing about the other examinees in
hunter hunter is that they're all so
arrogant to have got this far it makes
sense that they would be arrogant and it
may
since that they'd feel strong the weak
link was Lainey Mack underline who seems
to have been carried to this point by
his brothers teaming up during the exam
has been beneficial up to this point but
I do wonder when it makes more sense to
turn on each other that's something I'll
keep saying because I suspect that even
out in the real world passed this exam
they're going to have a lot of betrayal
incidents probably not with our main
three especially gone and karapa Kahoot
seemed to have some kind of wires loose
I'm not sure how they misinterpreted
don't come in as come here straight away
but um okay you do you I suppose
just to note my sarcasm here too if
there's anything I'm learning from the
writing style here the loyalty that's
being shown between these three is
absolutely going to be tested and
probably found wanting they've been
thrown together by happenstance and are
still together which is great but they
all want to be hunters for different
reasons so I'm excited to see at which
point their individual reason for being
a hunter overcomes that concern for
others they're recklessly displaying at
the moment the music at the end of this
episode was a strange choice and I want
to spend some time just thinking about
this I tend to have a lot of love for
the sound design of this series but the
flow of the episode and the size of the
new situation might have been better
served in my opinion with not a rocking
tune it seemed a bit extreme after the
lack of sound and the effect of it when
they got in there to finally Oreo on the
ground seemed a little overdone because
it was so short-lived going from he's on
the ground quick help him to okay he's
been patched up and we're going to leave
now levels of calm didn't really do it
for me particularly because they jumped
straight back into the hype of the
snakes appearing the electric guitars
active strings and heavy beat was great
for the exact moment of lay audio losing
consciousness but the second that was
over it just leaked energy from the rest
of the episode so despite all my
pleasure at their overall arc energy
control the result was that it felt they
were trying to force an emotion on me to
end this individual episode breaking the
flow of what felt good it's a great
example of how manga may not transfer
perfectly over to anime I don't begrudge
them trying but it felt a little flat to
me I am however excited to move on to
episode 18 because I want to know how
they get out of it so let's do that
episode 18 has left me wondering does
could a packet of a crush on gone before
you mock me he Mia
these are the things I've noticed
karateka sees everything but even more
than that he sees everything to do with
gone my first inkling was at the
beginning of the episode when GaN did
basically nothing in Caracas saw it
every episode that Caracas had anything
emotional to say about anyone it's been
about gone and how wonderful he is how
courageous how thoughtful how
magnificent his schnoz skills are
karappa car has never had anything
negative to say about gone that's not
bad per se but he seems to have some
serious limitations it's great to see
that he's trying to learn from someone
and maybe it's this teenager thinking
hey so this kid is younger than me but
he's dragging me through this exam
embarrassing but I'll take it because I
couldn't get through it alone it would
be good if core topic OHS noticing all
his own faults and shortcomings but he
doesn't phrase them as if he is he
phrases them as though he has an
obsession with gone that might be the
translation though also there are
several kinds of crush and several kinds
of love guitar Bakr could be in love
with god's abilities and frankly he
could be preparing to manipulate gone
the first step to using a tool is
understanding its purpose and how it
works he could be about to do that it
doesn't feel like that but in a meta
sense it feels more like the author
didn't know how else to tell the
audience that gahan was perfect deciding
instead to give him a personal
cheerleader so we know who we should be
following narratively
and who we should care about yeh gone
practically I think it means that
karateka has a crush on gone and that
sense got stronger the longer we spent
listening to cut uh pick a talk about
him and talk to him in fact any time
karappa goes interacting with God
I wonder on that note I love the
mechanic they've come up with to give us
insight into all the examiners minds and
their thoughts about who's left in the
exam at this point there are characters
still in the exam that we've never
really heard from or didn't care about
so it's nice to see our red shirts faces
before they're gone the effect of that
is to remind us that this is an exam and
that there is a body of people who are
checking really checking and judging for
a place of having been exam in
themselves sometimes something that
hasn't been disclosed as yet is how
they've had the ability to watch the
examinees they're clearly watching and
they clearly have seen what's going on
they also know because we were told that
they can see where tags go so they know
that his sole katuk Gon's tag and
returned it to him that little tidbit of
listen knowledge is quite tantalizing
and if they were to take it and use it
against the characters that would be so
very fun I'm really hoping that that is
something that happens just to note
because of the downtime involved in this
episode it had the makings of bored
chantal characters not actively doing
things no real conflict except there was
conflict well at the beginning of the
episode was the resolution of the
previous conflict and good job gone
because I fully expect him to find a way
to double-cross the only woman left in
the exam
doom anyone who thought the sniper was a
woman in episode 15 unfortunately not he
was referred to in masculine by the
mother maracas mover that guy so we just
lost our final woman who we got to have
for a few episodes it does make me
wonder why they made her a woman but I'm
sure there were reasons women like bees
maybe it's the bees something-something
queen bee I don't know what they were
thinking maybe there's a quota to meet
of making sure a woman is seen speaking
every five episodes or something
something to keep an eye on that I
weren't actively keep an eye on speaking
of women we got to see nat arrow again
the rarity of a group of finalists gave
me the feel of Pokemon no one at that
table but Notaro has seen this number of
newbies perhaps they'll be the ones to
change society after the exam it makes
me wonder in fact since everyone at this
table is a hunter what exams our mains
would set for people most of these exams
have been incredibly dangerous and I
don't think karateka and Lee Oreo would
set difficult enough tasks but I think
that might be something to think about
later I also have to admit that I missed
our old man and I love the way he and
Hisoka interact you all know my love
affair with Hisoka at this point but I
really enjoyed him trying to use his
presence to intimidate Notaro and
failing the music used during the scene
between the two was not hisoka's usual
flamenco it was instead a deep bass
guitar seductive preparing for a fight
he wasn't aroused he was focused and
implicitly threatening and that was
wonderful the purple of his speech
suggested he was half in his own mind I
love the use of the purple tones when I
speak of it to give us insight into
minds
it's a device we've seen before but it's
only ever been used for one mind the
shift here gives me some questions
did his Sokka say what he said entirely
out loud yes natera heard it but since
most other uses of the purple has been
to indicate what's being thought instead
of what's being said I find it
fascinating that the terror
was able to interpret it enough to
sidestep the experience having seen the
Tarot against both gone and quinoa
there's something exciting about being
seeded the idea that his Sokka and the
terror will fight at some point even if
it's very much in the future speaking of
my love mmm Hisoka it fascinated me that
his only interest in the exam is the
ability to kill without repercussion who
is it he wants to kill he sounds like
someone who wants to kill very specific
people rather than going on a rampage
for everyone there's very specific
physical needs after all does he have a
Goku s core a sh like need to be the
very best I do wonder how much Ora
accounts for why the participants chose
who they chose those who were expect to
complete the exam must have done a lot
of watching over the course of it
despite the fact that they haven't for
the most part seen each other fight the
old man I don't expect to pass at all
given his dismissal of Kela and gone as
children
he hasn't been observant enough that
everyone is avoiding or otherwise
watching the two children says a lot
about them what on earth is that one
dude thinking who watches crap Iike he's
out see you later dude it was nice
having you along but you gone and saw
mine if you enjoyed this video at least
do leave this video a like share or
subscribe and if you'd like to join the
fun then please do head over to the
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ori takes place on a daily
basis and finally do comment with your
thoughts on episode 17 and 18 of Hunter
hunter this has been the new worlds
review and I'll see you next time